hang out everybody uh today again we're
talking to Jen she's building her
movement of fantasy she is a copywriter
Jen say hello hello everybody thanks for
having me out so what's the latest
what's been happening it's been a month
I know it's been a month um you know I
have done a few videos a couple of them
were um around my book fantasy um and
then I did I just actually did posted
one this morning on copywriting that was
yeah right that was the assignment yes
exactly as my assignments I got it very
last minute it's kind of funny because I
you know when i'm doing my book that
book fantasy videos they're so easy
there just like you know and I'd like
you know tape it on the go or whatever
and I was stick a little more time and I
forgot how long it takes really more the
editing that anything so um but I have
to say having practiced doing some of
those little book fantasy videos was
great because it made me feel more
comfortable to do it more on the fly and
I have it all scripted out so so yeah
and then I think video what was the
packet of the video you posted this
morning just trying to get to your
channel um yeah it's there it should be
there do me to send you a link I'm going
now got here okay writing sub headlines
for sales pages okay cool yeah that's it
it's funny cuz it ended up being longer
she wishes so funny I don't know how
that happened okay so what else and I've
been billing Twitter up a little bit you
know I'm still pretty consistent with
her oats and why probably at my favorite
and most consistent channel um and face
because I think where I kind of need the
most work I haven't you know I thought
I've actually had a few people in the
last month uh you know they don't know
me just signed up I don't know exactly
how the family would there was you know
through YouTube or or something else um
you know guest post or something but i
have had probably like three or four new
people on my facebook page i like the
page so people i did i did know it all
so that's kind of cool every time I see
somebody I don't know my kitty Rhoades
yeah exactly I'm okay I was just looking
at your youtube page now I gotta go find
your Facebook page okay here we go um I
still would like to see so I haven't
seen this video yet I don't know II did
on purpose oh no no not at all actually
was gonna post it last night but I just
I didn't finish it yeah finish editing
um what can work for you I think Twitter
you get your you're rockin Twitter you
know you're you're doing a lot of
different things you're you're sharing
your your own thoughts you're putting
some quotes in there using hashtags
you're you're calling out other people
and give them credit the people um it's
a great start and and because of that
you're seeing you're seeing momentum and
movement there it's great yeah um
youtube how can we get how do we get a
consistent schedule with the same kind
of variety so got your book you know
great now we've got this copywriting one
that's great I know the last call we
talked about other potential videos too
they take a lot more time than the
scheduled tweet obviously um how do we
get it how do we get a consistent
schedule for you happen on youtube I
think if I just choose some more things
that I don't require as much editing in
a video process probably because I tend
to like um maybe overs think a little
bit like what I'm doing my for my video
stairs with my website sales page I
think okay I gotta you know show some
examples and I gotta edit this out and
it just needs a little more time and I
think if I were able to you know plan on
doing maybe one of those like every
couple of weeks uh maybe even once a
month and then do something maybe more
words just look around like giving copy
examples of someone else or I'm talking
about my experience you know using an
example without actually you know given
kind of a tip maybe a short tip or
something rather than you know a full-on
you know how to exercise that makes
sense yeah how often are you posting now
let's see your channel what's coming up
here yeah I'm not as often as I want to
I mean I think I'd posted since last
month I think
I posted 3 ok not rough work yeah
goodbye yeah if you know about once a
week I'd like to do I like to do more I
mean I'd like to keep what to do is have
like you know something relating to my
business once a week and then you know
for my book whenever I'm feeling it cut
the thing in a couple times a week maybe
even more yeah and there's nothing wrong
with you get in front of the camera and
and just talking with without having
that you can put in an intro if you want
and that like minor reading this stuff
but not do all of the cut two screens
and everything that you you tend to do
yeah those could be your your bigger
videos that you do spend more time on
but even just getting in front and
sharing something um could be like get
you some momentum going yeah um so
you're you're you're at a video are we
um which which isn't bad yeah and even
that that um well video week yeah I
guess you posted well the one that I'm
including mine that you posted the the
evident personation and the way now when
I was fine good and then before that was
a month ago and then and then three
months ago so it was oh yes okay okay um
I'd love to nail down kind of a
consistent schedule that you think is
reasonable if it's once a week keep it
on once a week look if you don't think
you can do more than once a week that's
okay but but with variety okay how can
we do once a week to start with variety
what what things can you talk about that
that you know you have a consistent
theme and that you know the first week
you're talking about this kind of thing
it is a client problem the next week
you're talking about a theory one of
your writing theories the next week
you're talking about an example
something that you liked I like those
ideas yeah I think do an example of
something I like and then yeah just just
a quick like even just a quick tip you
know just something really quick you
know
because I feel like you know I feel like
a lot of like my copywriting videos have
been sort of like process oriented um
and I feel like that the reader would
get or the the viewer would get a little
bit more out of being able to see a
specific example but the problem is some
of those examples take up so much time
in a long video um but if I just did a
really quick tip like it showed like an
example of one little headline or
something I don't know just something
where I can do a quick you can even know
you can say it without writing it yeah
talking about a headline or talking
about a paragraph um you know I I fella
should use this example I won't say the
name is the body line so there's a
company that a buddy of mine asked me to
promote and said hey these guys have
this new thing can you help me promote
it um and I'm you know so I took a look
at it and looked at the Twitter bio and
their Twitter bio was the most boring
thing I've ever written seen in my life
it's so technical jargon i boring no
feeling and this is a big company this
is a fortune 500 company okay I'm
thinking man I just want to make a video
and these guys right and yeah you can if
they don't listen people who who are
trying to write their own twitter bio
could learn from it and do something
better now I'm not going to do it
because it's a buddy of mine asked me to
help them not slammed them so fine but
that could be like an example for you
finding something that that is bad that
that you don't know or that you do love
you know um and let you know that the
true and company the bras I redid some
of their product scriptions I could do
something like that real quick I like
the idea doing Twitter bio I think
that's a great idea love that yeah
Twitter bio linkedin bio tag line um you
know as long as it fits into your
copywriting skill set and your you had
your seven things right of your process
of working with somebody right so you
can continue to remind people maybe you
pick a different one
each each week and you just keep
rotating through like one was headline
right I don't want I know well what was
the next one after headline uh there
were some headlines uh flow
customer-focused message um I should
know what I just did the video oh wait
and I talked about all of them yeah
that's important it's important you know
like some action it's just like you said
it's so second nature I don't think
about listen I'm all out but yeah right
I'll just in bank website sells page
yeah so your video just talked about sub
headline so you know I there's a lot of
different ways to do it I just think if
you if you um if you create a schedule
it's easier to stick to then I'm at the
video and I don't know what to do a
video on there's so many options and so
you don't do anything is like not you as
everybody it's common yeah totally I
totally great I'm by restricting the
creativity a little bit it gets stuff
done and then allows you to break free
and create more creative stuff once
you're used to that habit so you know if
you're talking about sub headlines you
could start with one video that that is
so this period video that that you have
coming up is you know you can have your
theory video like here's what you need
to know about sub headlines and then the
next video next week could even be a
follow-up and the here's an example of a
really bad sub-headline a really great
sub headline and how I would do it yeah
and tell a personal story you don't you
don't worry about the editing don't
worry about cutting to screen and
showing it you could just read it hey
and read it with um what I'll make it
entertaining and interesting is reading
it with uh the reading it with the
motion or lack of emotion so if it's a
really boring um sub-headline you read
it very boring Lee right fix it with you
reading it very fantasy Francis silly
fantastically but that's not fantastic
sick yes basically Francis Li whatever
uh so like if I was within reading that
Twitter bio it would be I would read it
very technical and boring and I don't
care about this company and then you
could rewrite it and then put it with
your own words I inject more emotion
into that I think that'll it's a lot
easier to do then worry about the
editing and the showing the words on the
screen and taking captures and mixing it
all together even where you are just use
your web camera to use a camera um I
usually use my iPhone okay it just fill
myself I've never tried using my laptop
it just it feels easier to use my my my
phone and use it on a tripod or what
yeah I can't usually level tricks to
lean up against things so that you know
it's know sometimes I just hold it I
have held it before yeah and those are
great for uh the handheld one you're
like at the trains right and praying
yeah yes those are great for like the
raw uh in the moment like I want to talk
about this right I got to get this off
my chest this is important for you guys
to understand right now right okay then
to have it shaky and whatever cuz they
they know that it's in the moment live
if it's a theory based thing or uh
here's an example it's better not to
have a kind of handheld shaky I'm just
saying where you are it looks great like
you know it's a simple background but
you got the corner you got the colors
you can do it off your web camera if you
do it off your phone no distractions but
a nice color color splash behind you
just get in front of the camera and talk
okay all right good yeah I'll try
sometime so what what well when I want
to leave today with a weekly schedule
ola okay things to talk about to prime
you here are some examples of things
that you're gonna make a video about so
that when you wake up Monday you know I
got the week to put this thing out right
and I'll do it thursday if thursday is
your
publish video day mm-hmm that's that
fits into your life or not but you wake
up Monday like okay I got until thursday
to get this video up here's the top of
going attack for them yeah just you in
general what you say thursday work for
you in general yeah it does yeah i mean
sundays work for leaking too I you just
a nice a really good day like I could
actually work on it on Sunday and then
like I haven't finished by thursday at
some of my deadline yeah I like that and
I love your idea of maybe even split up
like one you know being into several
videos like I'm thinking maybe like for
this month i choose call to action as my
thing and I just do a bunch of little
videos on different things about call to
action I could show an example if
someone's really great call to action i
can improve someone's call to action I
talk about my theory on call to action
sure that kind of thing so you've got
we've got uh you've got seven themes
right is it seven I think it's seven let
me go back and look for quite one of
those optional extras it's um so hold on
one second I'll pull it up so I make
sure get them all oh okay so so it's
headline customer focus message sub
headlines bullet points call the action
flow and then optional extras which is
like testimonials or guarantee or a
bonus or something like that so when
I've done now videos on flow and
headlines and sub headlights I'm so how
many were there in total there from that
list is the 734 sighs yeah they're seven
and you can I can stretch it out to
eight or nine depend on how you you know
if you want to talk about in detail
about the extras but yeah okay well
let's start with seven and then you know
this will probably change at some point
but it's a good structure to start with
so you have seven themes you got four
weeks typically in a month right how can
we how can we break up each each of
those seven things into four videos um
well I think I could do one where I just
um
you know talking just talked about a
quick tip about them so the theory or
why what's gallon here like my overall
theory okay overall very good um and
then I could show an example of a good
one hey that's number two okay um I
could um I could do like one where I'd
talk a little bit more about the process
behind behind it and then and then I
could actually do like actually do one
pic show an example of me taking a bad
one and and revising it or something
like that okay so okay 30 foot fix a bad
one like that okay so for the foot so
that the process one is that different
than the theory one yeah yeah okay okay
as long as you look at it and you'd like
you know week one you make the theory
and then you get to the process for like
oh I kinda already talked about that
yeah I think they're different cuz I
think I often will have I love series
the right word but kind of like yeah I
get my overall theory of it you know
like how they should be and how they'll
be most effective right away and then
that's totally different in the process
itself yeah okay so week one overall
theory week to example of a good one
week 3 process and we for fix a bad one
right it's great and you could start off
you could start off each one say okay
you know the first one is we're starting
new I'm starting a new theme this month
this month I'm talking all about call to
actions and then the importance our call
to action follow blog it into your
theory next week I'm continuing my theme
this month about how to create great
call to actions I wanted to share with
you an example the fantastic wonder why
it's good and then continue that so you
you remind people the theme every
weekend in the video and that I mean
that'll last you for seven months yeah
yeah line up the next seven months for
you and and you know it will probably
change I'd like you to do this for like
three months consistently and see how it
goes it will probably end up inject a
new things in but but having that
syston see for the next three months to
really help okay I did ah the other
thing on those I'd like you to think
about pay attention to attention to is
since you're a copywriter making sure
the title of the the video is well
written so what you call it that will
entice people to want to click on it so
you're this is a special important for
you because this is like you right feel
good night people won't hold you to a
high standard on your video but they
will on your coffee right right Rick who
I'm talking to right after this would be
the opposite right like they wouldn't
expect him to have great coffee but his
video better be killer because that's
what he does he takes pictures and video
so it'll help it'll help get people to
click on your on your videos and it will
also show off your your skills so I
really like what I called I need to work
on my movement building number your
hashtag fantasy number seven is brutal
verbal name right but you know i'm also
not held at that stand of either but but
I should do better um but I want you to
really think about what you're gonna
call each of these haha each individual
one and also your kind of your theme so
people can follow along with it yeah
yeah you know it's funny you should say
that cuz I do kind like I get torn about
whether or not it should be you know
really like really clear what it is or
if it should be kind of catchy and fun
um but yeah there's probably good
balance that we're trying to do so I
think there will be people who are
searching this stuff so if you have
keywords in there it'll it'll you want
to talk about what it is um and then and
then turn those keywords into something
catchy that people will will see that
and the one of the few on it yeah and
then you can use some of the things that
you say to put in your Twitter stream
and putting your Facebook stream I would
even put all the stuff you put in your
Twitter stream like put that to facebook
to but those quotes and you may not be
able to call people out in the same way
you know if you're retweeting something
but you could you could copy
paste that into Facebook you can copy
and paste the code that you really like
they're your retweeting into Facebook
and eventually I like the idea of making
them into pictures and you know your
background and all that but for now I'd
say just just take the stuff that you're
doing on Twitter and put it on the
Facebook and focus on youtube because
your twitter stuff is doing well the
facebook gets a little bit of an
injection but youtube is where we're
gonna we're gonna be yeah I agree well I
think actually most of my face my
facebook have found fans have family
through three you too so if I continue
to do good on youtube then it's just
going to naturally build up and rather
areas so alright cool I like it and then
for the the book updates you can add
those in when you when you're feeling
something don't feel pressured to have
to do it every day and then struggle to
kind of come up with something
meaningful if something hits you then
then make an update yeah okay that's not
what I've been doing lately so I know
and not just even the book it could also
be uh anything that hits you that you
love or you hate that you feel
passionate about you want to get on
camera and do a video vote yeah there's
this guy who's who who pissed me off
this morning and last night about he's
got this service that uh connects
mentors and mentees I volunteered to
help my friend out to help him mentor
some young entrepreneurs that are
starting out and and he makes me use
this software and the software is is
just clumsy huge waste of time my major
frustration and end up the CEO of the
company like doesn't listen doesn't care
and and went back and forth on emails
like I have to make a video about this
this is like this is brutal right and
yeah it's a way to rant and to get it
off my chest but also as an educational
tool for other entrepreneurs watching to
not treat people like this I
so you have your fixed videos that's
awesome but if you come across something
if you're shopping at sephora and you
man that's a awesome name for a new
lipstick you know you pull out your
phone and you make a video there um
anything related to your audience
something that you love something
related to fantasy something really the
copywriting um that hits you in the
moment you know if you ever feel the
need like you want to share something
with your friend or something think
about hey maybe I should share this with
my audience as well yeah okay and I'd
love to see a couple more those kind of
raw videos not like not super urgent not
have to be planned out if nothing
happens to the next month that's fine
but be good to start to train yourself
to think I'm feeling passionate about
something I gotta get this I gotta
capture this moment yeah so I'm gonna
make my I don't know I'm on the fence I
don't know what anything to make this
rob video the guy's name was rob i'm
gonna call i was gonna call it oh yeah
he definitely should do it i know i just
i feel bad for my friend because it's
it's his program it's his like he set me
up on this thing and i still have to use
the software he still has to work with
that guy so that's the only hesitation
if my friend wasn't connected yeah
that's a tough one I'm illogical might
learn from it so ya SE i sent one email
i'll see how how he responds there we go
you seem to be fired a bad at that i am
not i am i'm very tired up about it
don't be a wrong video but but you know
like when you get excited passionate
upset sides about something um priming
to capture that i'm like super
forgivable if there's zero editing of
the camera shaking or if you're you know
you don't see the perfect words you're
stumbling like that the passion will
make up for the you know using the wrong
words and for technology no that's
writing all that stuff okay yeah alright
cool hey I've one more question for you
um instagram do you do
surround yourself i'm not i'm not a huge
Instagrammer um no I don't and uh you
know you could you could try it um my
biggest challenge is their API sucks you
can't at least I haven't found a way to
to the post their through any of the
tools that I'm using okay and I needed
to be efficient so that's that's the
thing i mean it's it's a picture based
economy still so ah you know you can put
the pictures that you put it on facebook
or twitter and post there or you're you
know if you're in the store you find a
great piece of copy you can take a
picture and post it here your Instagram
right I'm just I'm not a fan of how
their technology does it integrate well
with the other tools and so I'm not a um
but yeah okay just carry so I don't like
you know I look at my daughter's age in
there they're all instagram they don't
use you know Facebook and it's still
it's a little young but I'm just curious
it's like seems to be growing and
growing and and curious if you had any
words of advice for it so yeah Instagram
and snapchat are the two I don't know if
your daughters in the snapchat now she's
not Sam shopping goodness what is enough
are the two are the two ones that are
coming like they're coming out instagram
the stuff lives forever so people post
like they're their best picture of the
night if you're going out having a
dinner you take the best picture in post
on Instagram where the snapshot is more
the the ongoing dialogue so you're
taking like live pictures of what you're
doing sometimes really inappropriate
stuff I because you don't think it
deleted right they don't they don't stay
there so there's no worry that your you
know your your parents will see it or
your dolly yeah the bigger target a
really young demographic then then
that's both of those where you want to
be and they're all still on facebook to
like your daughter's on Facebook this is
she she's not she's been on facebook
yeah I'm
interesting yeah but you know we really
didn't let her we actually just recently
started letting her let her do Instagram
so well our first experiment souhait no
she's still pretty young so yeah I mean
but most young people they're moving
away from facebook and looking at
Instagram snapchat being their
preference but but they're still on
facebook yeah so anyway I mean something
think about a guess and probably not
your market or anything you have to
worry about for the next you know yeah
5-10 years but but you can if you start
posting really good pictures instagram
could be something that you look at yeah
i mean only time I really ever see
Instagram is when I see somebody post
something from an Instagram on Twitter
so that's where I see it mostly yeah
honestly I look at it as like let's get
Twitter YouTube Facebook killing it and
then it's like happen you know I got
extra time I don't know what to do what
should I pray nice luxury to grow its
mystery of my daughter gets I think you
have a very good point though focus on
what I need to Phelps on for now yeah
yeah all right well I'm gonna keep you
posted i'm gonna follow your channel
still see these videos and does your
questions hit me up on email okay will
do thank you so much